hey guys it is monday the 24th of august
my name is just and he is punching you
Harmonix has been busy today not only
announcing 10 new tracks for rock band
floor but also pricing details including
the fact that the standalone Xbox one
edition costs twenty bucks more than
that for the ps4 while the ps4
standalone disc will cost a 60 bucks the
xbox one edition is eighty dollars due
to the inclusion of a legacy game
controller adapter the xbox one version
requires said adapter to ensure players
can use their existing xbox 360 guitars
and drum sets with the new game the
adapter supports four controllers
simultaneously and works with a bunch of
third-party instruments the vs board
doesn't run into this particular problem
and so it gets a slightly more
attractive price tag Harmonix also
released an instrument compatibility
chart so you can check out which of your
old instruments are likely to work with
the new game if you want to splurge on
new instruments again you can pre-order
a rock band 4 bundle with a guitar and
drum set for 250 bucks or just grab the
game and a guitar for 130 the game is
out on october six nintendo dropped a
ton of announcements today including the
release dates with Star Fox zero and the
Mario maker Wii U bundle Star Fox zero
will be landing in the US and Europe on
November 20 and we found out Xenoblade
Chronicles X is on its way come to stand
before Nintendo also confirmed that
Mario Tennis ultra smash will be out on
November 20 in Europe although it's
simply listed at holiday 2015 for North
America a walmart exclusive Super Mario
maker Wii U bundle will be out on sep
tember 11 for 300 bucks on the 3d aside
the legend of zelda triforce heroes will
be out on october 23 got a full list of
nintendo announcements check out our
story on games
finally access to the competitive
multiplayer mode of middle gear solid 5
the fans and pain appears to be behind a
paywall although this is currently under
some contention during his playthrough
of the game our reviewer Peter Brown
discovered the PvP mode entitled Forward
Operating Base we've not accessible
without the purchase of mb coins using
real-world money the access page
specifically States spend MV coins paid
service to purchase waters in the game
mb coins are used to purchase open water
to make space for a PvP dedicated space
online functionality was not accessible
during our review process so we can't
confirm what's going on here until the
server's go live on sep tember first we
reached out to konami the comment to
which they replied that the mode would
be quote fully accessible at launch and
the micro transaction layer to that
specific feature in the game primarily
acts as an accelerator our reviewers
stated he did not come across any mb
coins during his story complete
playthrough of the game let me know down
in that comment section what you think
is going on here you can as a game spot
where we've got stories on Diablo 3
seasons coming to consoles and the
updated rock band 4 setlist those are
all the things that I have for you today
be sure to leave me your thoughts and
feelings in that comment box and I will
catch again tomorrow